les États-Unis refusent on l'a appris
hier soir de livrer des chars lourds
comme les Abrahams à Kiev que faut-il
penser de ces arguments avancés par les
Américains sont-ils logistiques ou
politiques alors ce qui met en avant les
Américains c'est plutôt une dimension
technique en expliquant que c'est du
matériel très complexe qui est nécessite
un entretien coûteux et complexe et que
finalement le la présence de chars sur
le champ de bataille ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas ça ne fait pas tout et en
quelque sorte quel que soit l'équipement
et bien il n'y a pas d'équipement
miracle c'est ce qu'on a expliqué du
côté des des Américains alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on parle beaucoup
de Séchard mais cette réunion acte tout
de même quelque chose d'important c'est
que l'aide militaire n'a jamais été
aussi importante symboliquement on a vu
le Danemark crée la surprise en
annonçant qu'il allait tout simplement
donner la totalité de ces canons César
on a évoqué cette enveloppe américaine
de 2,5 des milliards de dollars la
France on parle beaucoup de la France
avec l'éventualité d'envoyer des chars
Leclerc mais la France envoie déjà des
AMX 10 5c des blindés extrêmement
performants on pourrait parler du Canada
de la Suède de l'Estonie tous ces pays
participent fortement à l'aide militaire
alors pour en revenir à ces chars et
bien évidemment que du côté ukrainien
les arguments américains on ne les
entend pas d'autant plus que c'est char
américain et bien les Allemands ont fait
un élément central de la possibilité ou
non d'envoyer des léopards 2 fermement
réclamés par le président
ukrainien alors du côté allemand et bien
on est sous pression Olaf Schulz et sous
pression au point qu'un certain nombre
de pays ont déjà annoncé que eux
allaient envoyer leur léopard 2 comme
s'il n'avaient pas besoin de Laval de de
l'Allemagne la pression est grande du
côté polonais on a entendu même le
ministre de la Défense lituanien
expliqué qu'il n'y avait pas de doute
quant à l'envoi de ces de ses chars et
puis
Ursula vanderleyen qui a tout simplement
expliqué qu'il fallait donner aux
Ukrainiens tout ce qu'il demandait tout
ce dont ils avaient besoin important il
faut quand même le feu vert de
l'Allemagne pour la livraison puisque
les Charlots Allemands sont production
allemande le chancelier donc olafol
c'est sous pression il est réticent il
est sous pression dans au sein de sa
propre coalition notamment sous la
pression des vers la pression des pays
Européens de l'Est vous l'avez dit à
l'exception de la Hongrie pourquoi la
livraison de ces chars lourds peut aussi
important pour les Ukrainiens en quoi
elle peut changer la donne sur le
terrain de la guerre pour l'instant la
situation est relativement figée
lorsqu'on regarde ce qui se passe du
côté de l'Ukraine notamment du côté du
nord ou du côté du Sud sur le front de
Kerson des positions bougent assez peu
même si les Russes tentent de reprendre
l'initiative du côté de de zapporija on
a vu bac route et Solidar ou les deux
camps s'affrontent de façon extrêmement
forte sans que aucun des deux ne prenne
l'avantage et les Ukrainiens sont
persuadés que la livraison massive de
chars ce n'est pas les 14 chars
britanniques qui suffiront et bien
pourraient faire balance faire pencher
la balance sur leur faveur alors ce qui
est intéressant avec ces Charlots par
deux c'est qu'il y en a beaucoup en
Europe il y en a dans 13 pays européens
quelques 2000 ce qui fait que on
pourrait en livrer d'après certaines
estimations entre 100 et 200 et pour les
Ukrainiens ça serait véritablement
quelque chose de nature à changer la
donne parce qu'ils ambitionnent toujours
de reprendre l'intégralité des
territoires et plus simplement de se
défendre face à la Russie en tout cas ça
ne se fera peut-être pas d'autant plus
qu'on parle de plus en plus d'une
offensive majeure du côté des Russes au
printemps prochain peut-être avant et
ses chars il faudra du temps pour qu'il
soit disponible au combat en quelque
sorte puisqu'il faudra les transporter
il faudra former les pilotes il faudra
mettre en place
des lieux des ateliers pour les réparer
pour les entretenir et du côté des
Ukrainiens on a bien conscience c'est
pour ça qu'on appelle à ce que ces chars
soient livrés le plus rapidement
possible pour qu'il soit opérationnel le
plus rapidement possible merci beaucoup
Karim Yahyaoui pour votre analyse merci
à vous les vœux